FLORIAN BERTELE: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the second
day of Google I/O.
I hope you had a
great first day.
And you're clearly
the most engaged crowd
because you made it to
the morning session.
So good job on that.
My name is Florian.
I'm the product manager
for the Places API.
And here on stage
with me is Ravi.
RAVI PALANKI: Good morning.
FLORIAN BERTELE: He's
the engineering lead
for the Android Places API.
And we would like to talk
to you this morning about
how you can understand
your place in this world.
And one of the things I
really like about Google I/O
is that it brings together
people from all over the world.
Right?
So I flew in from Australia.
And I'm pretty sure a lot
of you have also spent quite
a bit of time on an airplane.
And sometimes when
I'm on an airplane--
and when you fly from
Australia you always
have a lot of time
on your hands.
And you kind of relax.
And you sit back.
And you look out the window.
And sometimes, it hits you a
little bit that you say, wow.
The world is
really, really huge.
Right?
And we inhabit
such a vast space.
And humans have always tried
to structure and understand
their place in the
world around them.
And there's many different
ways how you can do that.
And if you look at this
medieval map here, for example,
this is one way how you
can structure the world.
Right?
So you see the globe--
and by the way,
that was an important
insight, that we in fact
live on a globe.
It took humans a couple of
iterations to get there.
Once you have that,
then you say, OK.
Let's put a coordinate
system on that.
And these coordinates are
called latitudes and longitudes.
And a set of latitude
and longitude
can describe a unique
place in the world.
That's one way of how
you can describe it.
And that's really useful if
you're navigating the oceans,
or if you are a geographer.
But it's not very
humanly feasible.
It's not very useful
in our daily life.
I don't think in
latitudes and longitudes.
Another way how you can
structure the world around you
is by saying, OK.
Let's use street addresses.
Right?
It works in most
countries quite similarly.
You say you have some system
of postcodes, a city, street
address, and a house number.
And all these things
together lead to a building.
And if you're getting
your parcel delivered,
that's really useful.
But then again, it's not
the most intuitive thing.
I maybe remember my
personal home address.
On a good day I remember
my office address.
But not much more, really.
So there must be
different ways how
we perceive the world around
us, how we memorize things
around us that we care about.
And that is really much
more of a semantic notion.
It's more about semantic places.
And what I mean by semantic is
that we are much more visual.
Right?
When we look around ourselves,
like here in Piccadilly Circus
in London, you see billboards.
You see storefronts,
signs, colorful things.
You see a bus at a bus shelter.
You see a historic facade
of a beautiful old building.
All these things are
what sticks in our minds.
So we remember
places by their names
and by their attributes
and their characteristics.
And understanding
the world in this way
is very much related to the
core of what Google does.
Because people search
for a lot of things.
And they search for physical
places in the world out there.
And they want to
understand these things--
when you search for Shoreline
Amphitheatre, for example.
So understanding the world in
this way is quite challenging.
Because first of all, there's a
lot of these places out there.
There's hundreds of
millions of places.
And all of these places
change all the time.
So we estimate that roughly
10% to 20% of places every year
shut down and open up again.
So you need to be constantly
updating all that.
And the third aspect that
makes it quite tricky
is that these places have
different types, right?
And you care about
a different type
of a place-- you care
about different attributes.
You care about an ATM
in a different way
than you think about
a hospital or a cafe.
So all of these things
contribute to the fact
that, well, doing places
is really, really hard.
And Google has its very own
unique approach in order
to get this problem right.
So what we do is we ingest a
lot of different data sources
and bring them all together into
one big representation of what
the places in the
world look like.
And I'd like to walk you
just through a few of these.
One of the data sources we
use for places is Streetview.
And as you can see by
the number of vehicles
that we drive around the
world, and the kind of vehicles
that you see there, we don't
just stop at the public roads.
But we go a little
bit beyond that.
And that's a tremendous
effort in order
to understand, what
does the world look
like from a street-level
perspective, when
you walk through a street and
you look at the storefronts
and everything like that?
Another information source that
we use is satellite imagery.
So satellite imagery
tells us about the places
and their building outlines.
It tells us about how these
buildings are located relative
to streets and other
points of interest.
And as you can see
from this example here,
we use satellite imagery also
for other interesting projects,
like Project Sunroof,
which tells house owners
how to calculate the solar
capacity of their building
and how much money they
can save by putting
solar panels on their roof.
Another source of information
are the users themselves.
Right?
We have so many people out
there using Google Maps.
And they all can tell us if
they think something is wrong
or something needs
to be updated.
And they say, hey, this place
has changed its location.
Or it has changed its name.
Or the opening
hours are not right.
Or maybe it has shut down.
So we get a constant stream
of suggestions from our uses
about what needs to be updated.
And last but not least,
another important source
of information for us are the
business owners themselves.
If you own a business, you
really care about the fact
that you're being
found if somebody
searches for you on Google.
So as a business owner, you can
sign up to Google My Business.
And when you have this
account, you can claim a place.
And you can say,
this is my place.
This is my store.
And you can make sure that
all this information in there
is right-- that it has the right
name, the right opening hours,
and it's in the right
place on the map.
So these are just a few
examples of information
that flows into
Places at Google.
And I'd like to stress
the fact that this
is a real unique thing.
This is a differentiator
if you compare us
to many other
information sources
that you can have for
places information.
This is really hard to do.
This is a lot of
sweat and labor that
goes into maintaining
this type of database
and keeping it up to date.
And so we share this
information with the consumers
through Google Maps, and with
developers from the Places API.
And what I'd like
to do now is to just
walk you through the main
kind of questions and problems
that you can solve when
you use the Places API.
The first kind of question
that you can work with
is to answer the simple-sounding
question of, where am I?
What's around me?
Where am I right now?
And the traditional way
how you deal with that
is that you use geocoding.
Right?
So you have, for example,
a latitude and a longitude.
And you convert
that with geocoding
into a street address.
Or you go the other way around.
And that's perfectly
fine for what it does.
But it doesn't really tell you
about the semantic layer on top
that I just talked about.
The street level or the
address doesn't tell you
what kind of place you're
going to find there,
and what characteristics it has.
In order to address this
additional layer on top,
you need some kind
of a descriptor
or an identifier for that.
And we use the
place ID for that.
So the place ID is
this unique identifier
that gives you access to all
these kind of semantic places.
And this has a
pretty broad scope.
So it pretty much
covers most things
that a user developer would
care about on a Google map.
We use place IDs to
describe establishments
such as restaurants
and cafes, points
of interest such as
a beach or a park,
and also geopolitical entities
such as a city or a state
or something like that.
And there are also a whole
bunch of other places
that we describe with
place IDs, such as road
segments, addresses like
your personal home address,
or also intersections.
What I'd like you to keep
in mind about the place
ID is that it is a
unique identifier.
So no two places have
the same place ID.
It is stable over time, which
means that you can store it
indefinitely for your purposes.
And it is global.
So that means as far as
Google's geodata goes,
we use the place ID
all around the world.
And now that we
have a place ID, we
can come back to just
answering this question about,
where am I right now?
So the Places API has a function
that's called getCurrentPlace.
And getCurrentPlace will
give you a list of places.
And each one of these places
is identified by the place ID.
And it comes with a
likelihood attached to it.
And this likelihood
expresses the confidence
that Google has that a
user is at a certain place
at a certain time.
And I want you to
keep this likelihood
here in mind for a little
bit later when Ravi speaks.
Because he's going to
go into much more detail
and explain to you what this
likelihood really means.
It's quite interesting.
Another way how you can tell
where you are at the moment
is, well, just ask your user.
But ask them in a
nice and friendly way.
So what we offer for that
is called a Place Picker.
So this is a visual
experience that
allows the user to drag
and drop a pin on a map.
And once you've
done that, then it
shows you a list of
the nearby places.
That is really,
really convenient.
For example, if you want
to build user location
sharing into your
app, and you want
to get the same experience that
you get, for example, right
now on Google Hangouts, when
you tap Share My Location.
Another kind of key question
that you may ask is, well, OK.
Now I've retrieved the place.
So what's at this place?
Tell me more information
about this place.
And what we give you
for that is something
called a Place Details request.
Place Details gives you
a lot of information
about the semantic
nature of a place.
It gives you, just like
geocoding, the street address
and the latitude and longitude,
but much more than that.
It gives you the
name, which is how
most people identify places.
It gives you a place type.
And the place type is
really, really actionable.
Think about it.
If you're building an app that
has a number of notifications
in it, the notification
behavior of your app
may be completely different
if you're in a quiet place,
like a hospital or a
library, as opposed to you're
in a busy commercial
place, like a mall.
It also has contact details
that makes your app much more
actionable.
Right?
So if you're adding to the
description of where a user
right now is, if you're adding
the website or the phone
number, then they can just
call up and make a reservation,
for example.
It has store opening hours in
there, which is really, really
important for many users.
Because in many use cases,
you only care about places
when they're actually open.
Otherwise, who cares?
And it has reviews and ratings.
That is really, really
important if you're
trying to make a choice
about whether you
want to go somewhere.
Many people really
rely on these ratings
and say, I never go
to a place that has
less than a four-star rating.
The second piece of information
that we give you are photos.
We have millions of
photos in the Places API.
And we make them all
available to you.
So you can build a really
visually rich environment
and experience for your users.
And again, it
helps the user more
to understand what
a place is about
if you're adding more
photos to your application.
If you're looking
at a restaurant,
seeing more photos of the
place-- seeing what it looks
like from the inside, from
the outside, what a menu looks
like, does the food look
good-- all of these things
help you understand,
what is this place about
and do I care about this place?
Which brings me to
my third point--
how you can discover
places around you.
So, tell me more about
interesting places around me.
One way of doing so
is using Autocomplete.
This is a really, really popular
feature that a lot of apps
use these days in order to
help the user discover places.
If your user knows
the name of a place,
or they know a part
of the street address,
they can just start typing.
And as they type,
Autocomplete gives them
an interactive experience
where you just, as you type,
get suggestions of
places that look
like what you've just typed.
And then you just select
it from a dropdown box.
So for example, if you're
building a ride-sharing app,
and the user wants to enter
the destination of where
they want to go to, Autocomplete
is a great way of doing that.
And the other way how
you can discover a place
is through Search.
Search is a really,
really interesting one.
Because a good search
result means something
very different to everybody
depending on what use case
you have.
And if you think
about the factors that
go into what a good search
result means to you,
it could be many
different things.
Right?
So you search for a
particular string.
And of course a
good search result
is a result that
matches your search
string in a very good way.
But there's other
factors, as well.
Proximity is an
important factor in order
to determine, OK, so
there's a place that
has a name that looks similar
to what I've searched.
But is it close to the area
where I wanted to get it from?
Another factor is the
prominence of a place.
You may want to
rank places higher
that have a high prominence.
By prominence I mean,
are they popular?
Are many people going there?
Does it have positive
reviews-- that kind of thing.
And the last point is that you
may have a personal bias in how
you want to see places.
You may care about certain
characteristics of a place
much more than others do.
And therefore you want certain
places to be ranked up higher.
So let me walk you through
a couple of examples
to illustrate what I
mean by all of that.
Let's start with a
very simple example.
Let's say you search
for Sydney Opera.
Sydney Opera as a
fairly specific string.
And if you search for that, the
only matching place for that
is the Sydney Opera House.
So you just get one
result. And that's
what you see as a red
dot here on the map.
That's very simple,
and very feasible.
Let's make it a
bit more complex.
Let's say you search
much more generic.
You search for cafe in Sydney.
In this case, what happens is
cafe is a very broad terms.
So you have a lot
of places matching
this kind of search string.
And Sydney is a very
broad term, as well.
Because the city of
Sydney is pretty large.
So you get a lot
of matching places.
So what the Places API
here does is it gives you
a set of search results.
And you see here
the top 20 results.
And they're ranked by both
prominence and proximity.
So it will select places that
have both a high prominence--
they're really popular--
and they're fairly centrally
located within Sydney.
Now let's make the search
a little bit more specific.
Let's say you care about
expensive cafes in Sydney.
If you do that, you're going
to see that the search result
set looks completely different.
So here the places are
much more spread out.
It will search for
places only that have
a certain minimum price.
And you see that this
affects the prominence
and the proximity of
these results as well.
So they're much more spread out.
And you're going to see
that a lot of these places
are actually located around
waterfront locations, which
leads me to understand
what I always suspected,
which is that you're not just
always paying for the food.
You're also paying
for the views.
And another way you can
introduce bias to your search
is by having proximity bias.
So you can be very
specific and say,
I want to search for a cafe
near Circular Quay in Sydney.
Circular Quay is
a ferry terminal
that I've highlighted
here with a green arrow.
So in this case, you will see
that the search results cluster
around Circular Quay.
What's quite interesting
here is that there's also
a couple of search
results which are
a bit further down and a bit
further away from Circular
Quay.
And you may ask,
well, why is that?
Are there not any
other cafes which
are closer to Circular Quay?
And the answer to that
is that, well, prominence
also plays an important role.
So these places that
are a bit further away
may have a higher prominence
than the cafes which
are directly there.
So this kind of result is
Google's way of telling you
that it said, look.
I found you a couple of
places which are really
close to where you're looking.
But there are a couple of other
places that are really popular.
And maybe it's worth
the walk to go there.
So this was a brief
overview of the whole set
of functionalities and
the kind of use cases
that you can cover
using the Places API.
And the Places API is available
on a number of platforms.
We have a mobile native library
for Android and for iOS.
You can use it as a web service.
And you can use it also
as a JavaScript library.
And going forward, we would like
to now focus a little bit more
on the mobile native APIs.
Because they have a number
of really interesting
characteristics and features.
And that is what Ravi will
tell you much more about.
RAVI PALANKI:
Thank you, Florian.
And good morning, everyone.
I'm Ravi, the engineering lead
for the Android Places API.
And as Florian
mentioned, I'm here
to talk about mobile native
APIs on Android and on iOS.
And I want to explain the
advantages of these APIs,
and not just give you
a list of advantages.
I'll go through the technology
behind these advantages.
And I'll illustrate
with examples
why these advantages
exist for native APIs.
In my view, there
are three of them.
One is that mobile
APIs are easy to use.
The second one is that
they're battery friendly.
And the third one is that they
give more accurate results.
So let me go through each
of them with an example,
starting with the first
one-- ease of use.
Let's say you have
an app which wants
to get the address of a place.
That's one of the
most basic things
that you could do
with a place, right?
Get its address.
You could use a web
service for that.
The Places API will
return your data.
But it returns a big
XML or JSON response
from which you would have to
extract the address yourself.
On the other hand, if you
were to use a native API,
say on Android, you would
get a Place object back.
And this Place object
is very structured.
If you want to
extract the address,
you have a getAddress method.
You want to get
the phone number?
There's a getPhoneNumber method.
So this is much more convenient
than getting an XML response
or JSON response
and parsing that.
But it's not just
about avoiding parsing.
On mobile, we offer
these two Widgets
which make it extremely easy
for a user to experience
the power of the Places API.
On the left, you see the
Place Picker Widget, which
shows the user's current place.
And you allow the user to
select either that place
or any other place on a map.
On the right, you see
the Autocomplete Widget,
which allows the user to start
typing in a string-- say,
in this case, "shore"-- and
that would autocomplete it
to the place that the user
was looking for-- presumably
Shoreline Amphitheatre-- as
the string keeps getting typed.
So these widgets are
easy to use for a user.
But it's not just about
the end user benefit.
It's also extremely
easy for a developer
to integrate them into an app.
What you see here is a snippet
of code for launching the Place
Picker from an Android app.
It's literally just
three lines of code.
And you get this beautiful
user experience, which
allows the user to pan
a map, select places,
shows the current
place-- all of that, just
for three lines of code.
So that means that
as a developer,
you don't have to worry
about these things--
the user experience and stuff.
We take care of that for you.
And you can just focus
on your use cases.
And it's not only about Android.
We have the same
Widgets on iOS as well.
And they're equally
easy to use on iOS.
And if you want to try
this out yourselves,
you can always go
to the Codelabs.
Check it out.
You'll be able to do
it yourself in no time.
OK.
So the fact that we
have structured data
and you have these Widgets
makes the native APIs
very attractive from a
developer perspective.
And with that, I want to move
to the second advantage, which
is that we have engineered these
native APIs to be very, very,
very battery friendly.
And I want to again
explain with examples
why they're battery friendly.
So let's go back to the same
example of getting data-- say,
the address-- from [INAUDIBLE].
If you use the web
service, by definition
it would actually
contact the web.
And on a mobile device, it has
to do that over some radio.
It could be Wi-Fi.
It could be cellular.
It could be something else.
Right?
It contacts it over some radio.
Now network calls
tend to be some
of the most
power-hungry operations
that you can do on
a mobile device.
For instance, a network call
that you make over 3G radio
costs 1/3 of a milliamp hour.
Many of you may be familiar
with what a milliamp hour is.
Some of you may not.
So a milliamp hour
means that you're
drawing a current
of one milliamp
for the duration of one hour.
And I use this unit because
this is what batteries
are measured in, as well.
A typical battery, for
instance, would be something
like 1600 milliamp hours.
There are batteries
which are larger.
which are smaller.
But this is fairly common value.
Right?
Now that 1/3 milliamp hour,
and the 1,600 milliamp hours--
let's put that in perspective.
Let's say you had an app
which was only making network
calls, not doing anything else.
It's just making network calls.
If that app were making one
network call every minute,
it would drain a third of
their battery in a day.
Right?
Even though it was not
doing anything else.
So you can see why this is
a power-hungry operation.
OK.
Great.
So how do we do
things differently
from the web service
on Native APIs?
We make use of the
fact that people
visit the same set of places
over and over and over again.
That picture here is actually
a very good illustration
of my life.
I go to work.
I go home.
If I want to spice things up,
sometimes I work from home.
[LAUGHTER]
Now I hope your life is not as
boring as mine, for your sake.
But it's still true
that, if you imagine it,
most people end up visiting the
same set of places frequently.
And only occasionally do
they visit new places.
And we can make
use of this fact--
that people are
creatures of habit,
that they are repetitive
in their patterns.
And we cache data about
those places on-device.
And when we cache
this on-device-- let's
say your app calls, hey, give
me the address for this place.
We don't have to
make a network call.
Because that's already
there on-device.
Maybe some other app
requested the same place
because the user
was there before.
And the fact that we can get
this data out of the device
means that we don't have to make
those expensive network calls.
And that in turn means that
the app consumes less power.
And it's good for battery.
And the fact that an
app is good for battery
also means that
users are going to be
happy with that particular app.
Because you can see which app
is consuming how much power,
right?
So the fact that
we're using caching
means that native APIs
make more battery friendly.
And that brings me to
advantage number three.
And this in my view is
actually the coolest advantage.
It is that you can in fact
get more accurate results
from native APIs.
How is that?
Let's consider an example
app of photo tagging.
A lot of people-- and I
mean a lot of people--
end up taking pictures of their
food and posting it online.
I have no idea why they do that.
But they do it.
So one of the most
common things that you
would want to do to such a photo
is attach the location or place
where it was taken.
Now, photos have EXIF
tags where you can
put in latitude and longitude.
But what does an EXIF
tag really give you?
It will give you a pin on a map.
But that doesn't carry
any semantic meaning
to me, or to anybody.
For instance, I would
never say, oh, I
went yesterday to
37.3861, minus 122.0834,
and I had great food at
that particular coordinate.
Nobody says that.
Well, no normal
person says that.
Right?
OK?
So it has no semantic meaning.
So as an app developer,
what app developers do
is try to convert this to
something that's better.
And using reverse
geocoding, this
can be converted to an address.
In this case, this lat-long
maps to 903 Castro Street.
That's definitely better.
But it still doesn't carry a
whole lot of semantic meaning.
Again, I probably don't say,
oh, I had great food yesterday
at 903 Castro Street.
We don't say that.
Right?
That's one problem.
There is a second,
potentially bigger problem
that if you look at the map
you can actually identify.
903 Castro Street here is the
address of a bicycle shop.
And again, most people
don't eat at bicycle shops.
Right?
So why did reverse
geocoding get this wrong?
Why did it not actually pick
up the restaurant nearby,
and map it to a bicycle shop?
And the answer is
the location that you
get on your device--
the lat-long that you
get on your device-- is
inherently not perfect.
That is because it relies on
sensors such as GPS or Wi-Fi
and other sensors like
cellular readings, which
by themselves are also
inherently not perfect.
And this is especially
true if you're indoors
where GPS does not work.
So what are you getting when
you take latitude and longitude
from your mobile device?
You're not getting a
single, perfect point.
You're getting a point,
plus an uncertainty circle
that is around that point.
And reverse geocoding,
on the other hand,
ignores this uncertainty circle.
It just looks at the
center of that circle.
And it says, oh.
Yeah.
The nearest place is
903 Castro Street.
I'm going to map it to that.
So that's the two disadvantages
of using reverse geocoding.
One is that it gives
you an address.
And the second is that
it makes this assumption
that the lat-long is
perfect and just maps it
to the nearest address.
OK.
On the other hand, if
you use the Places API's
getCurrentPlace method,
it can actually give you--
and it will actually give
you-- the name of a place.
And more often than
not, it gives you
the name of the correct
place-- in this case, Morocco's
Restaurant.
And now again we'll go into
a technology deep dive.
How is getCurrentPlace
able to do
this when reverse geocoding was
not able to do the same thing?
Right?
Reverse geocoding just took
the lat-long [INAUDIBLE]
the wrong thing.
And the answer here goes
back to what Florian
was mentioning initially.
Google has this vast
database of places
and a lot of details
about those places.
And getCurrentPlace makes
use of that information,
while other systems don't.
Right?
So it actually makes use
of all of this information.
And like with many other
great products at Google,
we also harness the
power of machine
learning to make use
of that information.
Let me give you, again, an
illustration of the technology
behind this and how that works.
One of the things
that this database has
is opening hours of places.
Let's say it's 8
o'clock at night.
Most restaurants, or at
least many restaurants,
including this particular
restaurant, are open.
Whereas bicycle shops tend to
be closed at 8:00 in the night.
Now at the time the
photo was taken--
let's say it's 8 o'clock.
This machine learning
system would know
that it's late in the night.
The restaurant is open.
The bicycle shop is closed.
And therefore it can give a
higher rate to the restaurant
compared to the bicycle shop.
So that's one indicator that
it makes use of-- the fact
that some places are
open at certain times
and others are closed.
And that's not the
only indicator.
Popularity of the place is
another great indicator.
By definition, popularity
of places-- people
tend to be at more
popular places
than at less popular places.
And this is something
this machine learning
system makes use of.
Geometry of the place-- the
fact that you have outlines
of buildings and you have
an uncertainty circle.
The uncertainty circle you can
correlate with the building
outlines and see whether you
are likely to be in a building
or outside of that building.
And you can again see that.
If the uncertainty circle is
tiny and you're within that,
it's very, very likely
the system will say, OK.
You're within this place.
And last but not least,
signals on device.
So signals such as Wi-Fi,
signals such as beacons--
the system can
process all of that
and give different weights
to different places based
on the signals
that it is reading.
So great.
It processes all of this
information-- opening hours,
popularity, geometry,
Wi-Fi signals,
beacons-- and gives you a list
of places and the likelihood
that the user is
currently at that place.
And you can see here that it
was able to predict correctly
that the top-ranked place
was Morocco's Restaurant.
And I want to
stress this again--
it was able to do that
even though the lat-long
corresponded to a
different place.
And it was able to do
that only because it
made use of
additional information
that the Places API
has about opening hours
and things like that.
So this is very, very powerful.
Not only are you getting
a semantic place,
like the name of the
restaurant, but you're also
much more likely to be accurate
using getCurrentPlace compared
to using reverse geocoding.
And that gives your users
exactly the experience
they're looking for, which
is in this case tagging
the photo with the
name of the restaurant,
and not a lat-long
or an address.
Cool.
OK.
So good.
So I showed you
how getCurrentPlace
can work for this app.
Now how can it
work for your app?
And we have two
recommendation that we'd
like to make here in case you
plan to use getCurrentPlace
in your app.
The first thing is to make sure
that the user's location is
turned on.
Now obviously if
location is off,
given that this machine learning
system is relying on location
as an input-- and Wi-Fi and
other signals as an input--
it's not going to work.
So make sure that your users
do have location turned on.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
work-- and not just location,
but high accuracy location.
And this is something that
can be done easily using
the location settings dialog.
You can prompt the
user to turn it on.
So that's recommendation
number one.
Number two-- if
you're a developer who
is working with a
store owner and you
want to build an app, say, that
uses getCurrentPlace and wants
to verify it's a particular
store or something like that,
make sure that the data about
that store or that place
is accurate.
Again, this should
not be a surprise.
We are making use of
all of this place data
in the machine learning system.
Obviously if the
data is incorrect
the system also can likely
make incorrect predictions.
So make sure the
data is accurate.
And this, for store
owners especially,
is very easy to do using the
Google My Business interface.
OK.
So that actually concludes my
deep dive into native APIs.
At this point, I want to
hand it back to Florian
to summarize this talk and leave
you with a few key takeaways.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FLORIAN BERTELE: Thanks Ravi.
RAVI PALANKI: Thank you.
FLORIAN BERTELE:
Thank you, Ravi.
I hope you really
enjoyed this kind of look
behind the scenes of what
goes into getCurrentPlace
and what goes into this
kind of place likelihood.
To me personally
it's very fascinating
how you can take a very
simple question like,
where am I right now?
And we answer that
with a lot of stuff.
We answer it with a lot of
data, with machine learning,
and with sensor data, in order
to give you a really accurate
result. So that's really cool
Great.
So let me round up this talk.
So you're going to go through
a lot of different sessions
today.
And you're going to hear
about many other APIs.
I want you to take away at least
three things from this session.
Number one is keep in mind
that places in the world
are semantic.
Take advantage of the semantic
nature and all of these things
in your app to make your
app more user-friendly,
give your users more context,
and help them make decisions.
And number two is, if you
face these kind of questions--
where am I right now?
Tell me more information
about where I am.
Give me more details.
Give me colors.
Give me pictures.
That's when the
Places API helps you.
And number three is what
Ravi has illustrated really
beautifully.
If you're building
an app, really
consider using the
mobile native APIs.
Because it's going to make
you as a developer happy.
You save time writing codes.
The battery is
going to be happier.
That makes happier users.
And at the end, you even
get more accurate results.
Great.
So what you should
do next-- you can
get started coding straight
away with the Places API.
We have two amazing Codelabs
for iOS and Android,
which help you
get started so you
can write your
first lines of code
and try out what it's like.
If you have questions, we're
going to be after this session
straight out there and happy
to have a chat with you.
And we also have a Space
on spaces.google.com.
So if you have later a question
and you just want to type,
we're happy to answer that.
And of course, we have our
developer documentation.
Great.
So this is how you can
understand your place
in this world.
I hope you have a great
day at Google I/O.
And thank you very much
for attending this session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]